(bluesy rock music)
- You're doing it again.
- Doing what again?
- My therapist says.
- Oh my God.
- [Voiceover] You haven't
moved in like three days.
You kinda just walk around moaning.
- Ugggghhh.
Uuuuugh!
- What?
- Nothing. Just, everything.
Yeah, it's that time of year.
- The most wonderful time of the year?
(bouncy, electronic
version of "Jingle Bells")
- Oh, December gloom.
When you feel sad and anxious,
and empty, hopeless, helpless, worthless.
Guilty, irritable.
- Yeah, you're S-A-D.
- Yeah, sad, right.
- No. Seasonal Affective Disorder.
- Oh my God.
Stop it with your therapy terms.
- OK, my therapist says.
- My therapist says.
My therapist says. My therapist says.
- I don't sound like that.
- My therapist says.
- OK, my good friend who has
a PhD says it's perfectly
normal to feel this way
during the holidays.
I go through it every year.
Don't want to get out of bed.
Seeing everyone super
happy with their families.
Mournfully opening the present
you got for your ex last year.
- Yeah, it's called December gloom.
- But, going to therapy
helped me see that there were
larger issues there.
- Anxiety, co-dependency,
emotional hoarding.
- But they just, you know, get intensified
during the holidays 'cause
there's such a focus
on happiness.
- I just don't wanna
become one of those people.
You know?
- An emotionally responsible person?
Yeah, they suck.
- One of those people
who write off their flaws
by labeling it something clinical.
You know, like, oh Jimmy,
Jimmy, he's workin' on
it, but he has assholes.
- Oh yeah he started a fight
with all the other dads
at his son's soccer game.
- What are you gonna do?
He has assholes.
- Assholes runs in his family.
- He's doin' his best.
- You know he cheats on
his wife and he beats her,
but what are you gonna do?
He has assholes, he's workin' on it.
- Oh or like when people will just like
misdiagnose themselves for
something more serious,
you know?
- Yeah.
- Like.
- Until the new season
of New Girl comes out,
I'm like depressed.
- Yeah no you're not.
- No you're not, bitch.
- No, you love adorkable television.
You don't have a
crippling mental disorder.
- But, you know there are people who do,
who once they go to therapy,
it starts to get better.
- It helps you?
- Hell yeah.
Especially when I want
the perfect text response.
OK, so that's what she said to me,
but what should I say back?
- Mmm. Maybe something like, "I hear you."
- Mm-K. All right.
I'll do it.
- Good.
Will you also clean this shit up,
'cause I live here too,
and you're kinda being an asshole.
- Oh, well I.
- [Voiceover] Thanks.
- I have assholes though.
- [Voiceover] Shut up.
- You'll see, I'll got to your therapist.
Let you know I have messies.
I have messy disease.
I'm just messy.
Sorry.
(bluesy, energetic rock music)